alors ça a pris dix kilos 1 le foie gras
le saumon fumé tout ça les amis
aujourd'hui cette petite vidéo pour
faire un petit point sur 2016 vous
parlez de plusieurs choses 2016 selon
moi ça a été une année assez ou face et
bien remplie en vidéo on a fait plein
plein de conneries cette année et je
pense vraiment que c'est l'année où on a
sorti le plus de vidéos cool
en tout cas qui me plaisent à moi et
dont je suis fier parce que oui a
forcément des vidéos que qui sont bien
mais tu les mets en ligne tu fait bon
être pas incroyable et d'autre tout est
vraiment content et l'ac thann et j'ai
vraiment fait une majorité de vidéos je
suis très content du résultat et tout ça
c'est grâce au fait que maintenant j'ai
une bosse plus tout seul je suis avec
clément que vous connaissez déjà et qui
notamment de quatre jeunes et de htc
live etc
ça permet de ne pas être seul dans mon
coin ne pas m'isoler du monde est vivre
les choses et d'apprécier encore plus
mon métier aujourd'hui qui est d'être
titulaire c'est un métier c'est un
métier à cela s'ajoute le fait que
maintenant j'ai ce nouveau studio qui
n'est pas chez moi et [ __ ] ça fait du
bien il ya pas mal de personnes trou qui
ne comprenait pas pourquoi c'était bien
d'avoir un studio et voyez ça plutôt
comme away c'est nul tu te
professionnalise c'est de la merde
s'était mis dans ta chambre tu as changé
non pas du tout au contraire en fait
maintenant dubuc suis plus chez moi je
suis plus entre les mêmes quatre murs de
10 heures jusqu'à minuit parce que ouais
je suis j'étais dans mon bureau quand je
jouais pour le plaisir et aussi quand je
faisais des vidéos et aussi quand je
faisais le montage est aussi quand je
buvais un café par ces horribles et ben
là je vais au travail comme tout le
monde matin je pars de chez moi comme ça
je suis dans les bouchons jeu rage et je
vais dans ce [ __ ] de bureau dans
lequel je me sens encore mieux que dans
mon ancien bureau parce que c'est pas
chez moi et quand je verrai si je sais
pourquoi je suis là je sais ce que je
vais faire ça m'a fait énormément de
bien et ça même au niveau des vidéos je
pense qu'on peut voir que je prends un
malin plaisir infini par rapport à avant
où je commençais un peu à être fumés
comme le saumon que tu as mangé il ya
quelques jours ça m'a permis de me
ressourcer de reprendre un mec de pied
dans ce que je faisais donc ça c'est
vraiment parfait et aussi à vous
remarqué que les vidéos sur un peu plus
mature
non ça fait bientôt six ans qu'on est
sur youtube les amis vous rendez compte
six ans à l'époque on était très très
jeune avait pas de barre on avait la
voix qui mue à mort pour moi le mieux
encore un peu mais c'est pas voulu et en
fait on a mûri on a grandi et je vois de
plus en plus de personnes qui retombe
sur les vidéos qui ai parlé depuis trois
quatre ans et qui maintenant apprécié et
il ya même une sorte de truc qui
consiste à avoir un peu honte de dire
qu'on apprécie vidéo de ce quiz et en
2016 mais ça change le contenu évolué
nous avec et du coup ouais ça m'étonne
pas en fait c'est plus mûr c'est moins
on fait des vidéos un peu plus posé je
trouve parfois un peu quand même un peu
plus réfléchi avec un but psychologique
comme sur pas mal de jeux qu'on a fait
cette année et ça avait l'air de vous
plaire à fond donc je suis hyper content
j'ai reçu plein de messages de gens qui
ne faisaient qu avant ils étaient testés
les vidéos et maintenant ils aiment bien
les trouve ça un peu plus posé un peu
plus mature et c'est bon je veux quand
même pas qu'on fasse des vidéos sérieuse
de la faune mais en tout cas dans notre
connerie on est plus mature qu'avant ça
c'est sûr voilà je suis vraiment
moi-même j'aime ce que je fais c'est que
des fois je suis un petit peu plus posé
dans des vidéos que dans d'autres des
fois j'ai un peu plus fou fou et je
crois que le contenu que je fais ma
jamais autant correspondu je vais pas
vous mentir cette fin d'année elle était
très très chargée à cause de the last
guardian fin à cause c'était pas
vraiment un truc que j'ai subi mais au
comptage est hyper apprécié mais
c'étaient des vidéos ça faisait du
montage à faire en plus c'est du temps à
passer en plus à tourner alors c'était
très kiffant mais le seul souci c'est
que ça s'ajoute aux vidéos que je
faisais déjà de base donc les quatre vo
normal par semaine je devais en faire
trois ou quatre de plus et c'était celle
de the last guardian que ça faisait une
quantité de tafas est énorme et j'avais
peur d'être un peu démotivé par le fait
de doubler ma charge de travail mais que
les gens ne suivent pas le truc je veux
dire je laisse voir dire je m'attendais
pas à ce que ça marche aussi bien ça a
cartonné sur la chaîne youtube je suis
encore étonné qu'il ya autant de gens
qui est appréciée laventure qui est
suivi parce que c'est celle en des fois
on tourne un peu en rond dans le jeu fin
je retire les jeux cultes au montage les
passages aux stands en rond mais bon
voilà c'est quand même très posé très
lent c'est une ambiance particulière et
qui qui n'a rien à voir avec ce qu'on
fait habituellement
et [ __ ] en grande partie vous avez
adoré tous les épisodes ont fait au
moins un million de vues et j'étais
vraiment surpris et du coup je me suis
dit [ __ ] sas ça valait le coup de
doubler ma charge de travail parce que
les gens suivent ce truc donc merci pour
ça je sais que tricot vous manque
aujourd'hui que vous aimeriez que les
sodi s'entrelacent guardian de demain et
ben moi aussi s'ils peuvent elles me
sortir cet après midi ça ne va pas de
choses que c'était le meilleur truc
qu'on pouvait faire pour bien conclure
l'année à savoir faire un peu plus de
vidéos mais dans un délire complètement
différent quitte à ce que ça marche
moins bien et au final ça a pas moins
bien marché que le reste parce que vous
avez complètement adhéré et [ __ ] merci
mais du coup vu que cette fin d'année
était très très très chargé je me prends
des petites vacances
les amis demain je pars en corée du sud
j'étais déjà allé en mars pendant cinq
jours avant d'enchaîner sur le japon où
j'ai fait pas mal de blogs et en fait
j'ai pas fait énormément de choses là
bas et c'est mon plus grand regret je me
dis plaire mais je suis les cinq jours
en corée et qu'on me dit que ça fait là
bas
des boutiques je suis un boulot et
j'aimerais vraiment ne plus jamais avoir
cette réponse donc j'ai décidé d'y
retourner une semaine une petite faim en
huit jours pour être exact je pars
demain en début d'après-midi alors je
vous ai fait des petites villes ou
d'avant ce n'est pas trop en fait je
pars demain et je reviens du coup le 5
novembre janvier de novembre je reviens
le 5 janvier donc le jeudi d'après il y
aura des vidéos du coup cette semaine là
pas de soucis mais la semaine prochaine
donc la première semaine de janvier il y
en aura il y aura sûrement un ou deux
blocs de corée parce que j'ai trop vite
vous faire découvrir des trucs j'ai un
programme vraiment trop cool là bas je
me suis un petit programme ça va être
complètement barré vous allez adorer
j'ai vraiment envie de vous montrer un
peu ce que je vais faire là bas mais du
coup pour la première semaine de janvier
voilà j'ai rien prévu au niveau vidéo
avance parce que déjà en faire trois
d'avant ça m'a demandé pas mal de taff
et si j'en faisais plus les vidéos
allait être un peu pourri c'est des
vidéos dont je vais être un peu moins
fier parce que je me suis pressé un peu
pour les faire j'ai dû trouver les idées
comme ça rapidement et je sais que je
vais pas être content de mettre en ligne
sa me faire chier donc je préfère ne
rien mettre en ligne est juste vous
proposer les blocs de corée qui je suis
sûr vont vous plaire je reviendrai donc
le 5 janvier donc le jeudi et le 6 et 7
janvier j'ai un tournage pour une vidéo
qui arrivera à la fin du mois de janvier
sur ma chaîne du coup le retour de corée
va être un peu violent parce que ça va
être un tournage de [ __ ] sur 48 heures
on va bosser
38 c'est sûr mais [ __ ] ça va valoir le
coup en plus il ya plein de poteaux
youtuber qui sont dans le projet et hrt
vous montrer enfin bon tout ça pour dire
que 2016 pour moi sur youtube ça a été
je pense de ces cinq dernières années
passées à faire des vidéos
ça a été la meilleure dans le sens où
j'ai proposé les vidéos dont je suis le
plus fier j'ai fait les vidéos que je
voulais faire je ne suis pas forcer à
faire tel ou tel truc j'ai été le plus
moi même je trouve
et en plus j'ai eu ce donc ce nouveau
studio c'était une nouvelle manière de
bosser aussi avec clément et ça m'a fait
un bien fou
c'était le vent frais qui me fallait et
je pense que vous l'avez remarqué dans
les vidéos globalement parce que comme
j'ai dis même des gens qui regardaient
plus tous les vidéos écarts sont tombées
dessus a récemment ils se disputent un
mais c'est bien en fait maintenant et et
ça pour moi juste cette phrase c'est
enfin ce comportement là de gens qui
revient des années après et qui
apprécient c'est une victoire je me dis
[ __ ] c'est cool ça prouve que j'ai
voulu que je grandis que je mûris que je
propose des trucs différents qui
plaisent et qui plaisent plus parfois
aux gens parce que ça peut ne plus
plaire aussi mais que ça plaise ou non
sa marque l'évolution et je trouve que
c'est important d'évoluer dans ce que je
fais pas de trop stagner et de rester
sur ses acquis
voilà la millième vidéo par exemple on
n'est pas resté sur nos acquis en bref
merci pour tout j'espère et 2017 sera
encore meilleur jeu pas qu'on va pouvoir
faire encore meilleure parce que j'ai
jamais été autant épanouie on retrouvera
moyens vous en faites pas au pire si
saumon fumé bassam et bien sam épanouie
du coup je vous souhaite quoi là je vous
souhaite une bonne seconde semaine de
vacances un bon nouvel an un profitez
bien de vos cadeaux de votre famille de
votre nouveau pc gamer peut-être pour
certains ou de votre console merci pour
tous merci pour cette année moi je m'en
vais encore et finir en beauté l'année
puis je reviendrai bien en forme et pour
proposer des trucs encore meilleur
j'espère j'espère que les vidéos que
j'ai fait en avance pour cette semaine
vous plairont et plus on se trouve la
semaine prochaine pour du blog en corée
partez-vous vient surtout bonne fin
d'année pis